GONEN STEIN: There is a large
multinational security company.
And their challenge was
to migrate their existing
workloads from their
on-premise infrastructure
in multiple
geographical locations
into Google Cloud Platform.
Their challenge was that their
applications were very complex.
What they've done
with CloudEndure
is they were able to remove the
complexity entirely and convert
the systems into a Google
platform very, very simply.
A very lightweight
version of those systems
is being maintained in
Google Cloud Platform.
And it's only being spun up
when they actually need it.
And diverse customers
will continue
to use the cloud more and more.
And the cost
reduction that we've
seen among many of our customers
has been upwards of 90%